sein name ist willkommen meine lieben
freunde wie reagieren heute mal wieder
gemeinsam auf häuser die wir uns alle
nicht leisten können
ich kann mir nicht mal richtiges t shirt
leisten natürlich peking ex profi tor
wenn ich schon diese 34 millionen dollar
da so fühle ich mich wie eine maus ist
die
denn
ich bin so aber ich weiß nicht mal was
das heißt wird den lead ins
andere extrem reiche leute haben so
einen wellness raum die haben allerdings
direkt
[Musik]
genau das habe ich auch gesagt also du
legst dich in diese komische tief
kühlbox rein und es fühlt sich an als
wärst du im weltraum
bruder ich nehme und salzstreuer und
haute das gegen die wand da zahlst du
dich deine den 34 millionen oder 5 euro
pro nacht die stimme ist ihm das team
schauen
was kommt noch fitnessraum fehlt die
hunde klar ein fitnessraum direkten
hoben jim
ich finde ich gar kein club mehr von
diesem haus sehen
guest bedroom größer als meine ganze
wohnung machen wir nun allerdings weiter
mit einer riesigen villa die wir uns
auch
niemals in unserem ganzen leben leisten
können werden
leisten werden können was soll ich jetzt
mal deutschland anfang geld zu verdienen
ich kann mir nicht mehr so viele autos
leisten wie du garagen stellplätze hast
und das finde ich ja so schön
diese brüstung wir haben mit diesen
kleinen hammer beton denn drinnen keine
ahnung aber damit auch dieses muss
dieses grün so dass in amerika - und so
einen pool und so puller aus
ja
genau das meine ich
das sieht so richtig aus also es
erinnert mich zumindest an tote mädchen
lügen nicht bei diesem typen da wo der
die die so reich weil ich es vorbei
angekommen ich weiß nicht mehr ganz
genau beschreibt dann in die kommentare
aber es ist sehr sehr sehr sehr wild
[Musik]
ja
ich fühle mich selbst beim anschauen
nun allerdings weiter mit einem etwas
günstigeren
objekt und zwar kostet es unter vier
millionen dollar ist in washington dc
und eine kleine haus 11
aber trotzdem extrem niedlich
das erinnert mich einfach so krass an so
eine mischung aus amsterdam london und
hamburg von den häusern
das ist so niedlich schön perfekt und
mehr braucht man einfach nicht
ich war eigentlich nie ein fan von fisch
dreht auf dem boden also das ist ja
dieser art von holz was ihr da gerade
hier auf der seite eigenen sieht das ist
sagt übereinander gelegt wurde aber hier
sieht echt geil aus in den weißen wänden
und im schwarzen länder so sieht sehr
edel aus
[Musik]
also ich persönlich wird immer
bevorzugen auf so wenig ebenen
übereinander wie möglich zu leben weil
treppensteigen ist ist einfach
anschließen
wenn ich so viel geld hätte für
sonnenhaus dann würde ich da auch 40.000
treppenstufe und kauf nehmen
das ist auf der einen seite extrem geil
weil du sonst überhaupt kein richtiges
natürliches licht im bad hättest auf der
anderen seite sagt sich da natürlich
sehr viel dreck
[Musik]
das sieht so
unfassbar krause und persönlich aus
diese schlafzimmer und generell das
komplette haus das feiere ich einfach
viel mehr als das was ihr euch jetzt mal
eine blende das ist nämlich einfach ein
paar reiche paläste in dubai
sorry aber das für dich halt 0,0
hauptsache irgendwie die teuersten
materialien nehmen damit einfach nur
reich aussieht
es ist so wie diese leute die dann so
rumlaufen hauptsache alles voll mit
gucci und louis vitton und einfach nur
noch steil achten einfach nur das muss
teuer sein
bruder sie es trotzdem aus wie ein
hässlicher kennt
[Musik]
voll aus und finde ich das haus echt
ganz cool ich würde zwar mehr fenster
einbauen weil ich mag es nicht einfach
über eine zwiebel bzw generell
natürliches licht aber hier drinnen
wenn ich es einfach irgendwie echt auch
wieder so basic rich
wir brauchen marmor in der küche so viel
wie geht und der boden oder nehmen wir
einfach irgendwie so ein braunes glattes
holz das sich zur basic rich aus
irgendwie aber wir würden es natürlich
trotzdem übernimmt für 3,8 millionen
nicht mehr das hat die nicht in der
woche bis er
kann ich ihm nur zustimmen
du hast einen richtig geilen ausblick
ist mitten in der stadt also die lage
ist auch geil weil die meisten von
diesen ganzen riesigen villen die stehen
dann am arsch der welt weil du kannst ja
nicht er will einfach mitten in der
stadt bauen aber das hier sieht einfach
so unfassbar kaisers und es passt
irgendwie alles der steinen der
arbeitsplatte beim küchenblock ist quasi
genau welche fahrten wie diese fenster
vor was wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie
historisches oder sowie die angehaucht
und du bist einfach irgendwie doch wer
keine ahnung 70 oder so hasst so eine
höhe trotzdem sonne krasse deckenhöhe
und ich würde mir auch noch so eine
leiter so dran stellen dass auch legale
hin packen mit zu büchern leds
beleuchtung
bin ich nicht architekt geworden
wahrscheinlich jedes meiner gebauten
häuser statisch gesehen einfach
einstürzen würde
ich aber so scheiße waren matte
[Musik]
ja
ich feiere es übertrieben wenn man eine
garage nutzbar macht durch
beispielsweise noch eine party mit drin
steht oder irgendwie ein paar regalen
oder keine ahnung was aber warum
brauchst du vier fernseher
wie bist du ein wettbüro
[Musik]
ich hab euch das gerade einfach noch
durchlaufen lassen
[Musik]
in kochs 780 millionen dollar
ich würde 100 dollar zahlen und den
restlichen 86,9 millionen tilgen über
die nächsten 4000 jahre wenn es geht
[Musik]
spiele
das hier
gibt mir ihnen wie so etwas beruhigendes
du bist mitten im großstadtdschungel
hast aber trotzdem deine freie fläche
mit wahrscheinlich künstlichen gras
draußen
aber es ist so
du hast keine ahnung und
[Musik]
gibt es ein raum
der nicht
weiß und klein ist
das ist so kalt und kahl aus irgendwie
so wie man bat
er ist auch karl
lagerfeld der war auch karl
an der stelle sollte ich das heute
wieder ist allerdings glaube ich auch
besser beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
und dass noch geld einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
wollt dass ich weitere tik tok haus
reviews von häusern und residenzen mache
die wir uns leisten können dann schalten
wir gerne in die kommentare und zu guter
letzt wenn ich euch jetzt während des
autos noch mal ein haus ein und gefühlt
noch den ganzen park mit kauft
[Musik]